- So what I would like you to do
is see if you can figure out
the measure of angle DEG here.
So try to figure out the
measure of this angle.
I encourage you to pause the video now
and try it on your own.
All right, now let's work
through this together
and the key realization
here is to think about
this angle, it is an inscribed angle,
we see it's vertexes sitting
on the circle itself.
And then think about the
arc that it intercepts.
And we see, we see that it intercepts,
so let me draw these
two sides of the angle,
we see that it intercepts arc CD.
It intercepts arc CD.
And so the measure of this angle,
since it's an inscribed angle,
is going to be half the measure of arc CD.
So if we could figure out
the measure of arc CD,
then we're going to be in good shape.
Because if we figure out
the measure of arc CD,
then we take half of that
and we'll figure out what we care about.
Well, what you might notice,
is that there's another
inscribed angle that
also intercepts arc CD.
We have this angle right over here.
It also intercepts arc CD.
So you could call this angle C ... Whoops.
You could call this angle CFD.
This also intercepts the same arc.
So there's two ways you
could think about it.
Two inscribed angles that
intercept the same arc
are going to have the same angle measure
so just off of that you could
say that this is going to be,
that these two angles
have the same measure,
so you could say this is
going to be 50 degrees.
Or you could go, you could actually solve
what the measure of arc CD is.
It's going to be twice the
measure of the inscribed angle
that intercepts it.
So the measure of arc CD
is going to be 100 degrees.
Twice the 50 degrees.
And then you use that and you say,
Well, if the measure of
that arc is 100 degrees,
then an inscribed angle that intercepts it
is going to have half its measure,
it's going to be 50 degrees.
So either way we get to 50 degrees.